Piggy dit
[Musique]
ici Brian Tahar, directeur créatif senior
chez Insomniac Games, merci
pour tous vos incroyables commentaires,
la démo de la tournée au Showcase plus tôt cette année.
Marvel Spider-Man 2 est rempli d'une
histoire incroyable et de missions d'histoire.
Aujourd'hui, je suis  ici pour vous donner un
premier aperçu de l'
évolution de l'expérience du monde ouvert et de la manière dont le jeu
est conçu pour tirer pleinement parti de la
PlayStation 5. La
première chose que vous remarquerez est que notre
ville a presque doublé de taille avec l'
ajout de deux  les arrondissements emblématiques de Newark,
Queens et Brooklyn, et nous avons introduit
le Web Wings, un tout nouveau mécanisme
que nous combinons avec le Web Swinging
vous permet de traverser la ville d'une toute nouvelle
manière et d'avoir des vitesses plus rapides que
jamais, qu'il s'agisse d'un
décor de quartier de reines ou  les feux d'artifice qui
illuminent le ciel de Coney Island en
explorant ces zones seront très
différents des gratte-ciels imposants
de Manhattan tout en offrant également
des lieux mémorables comme l'
ancien terrain de jeu de Peter Parker à Midtown High et le
lieu actuel d'apprentissage de Miles Morales,
Broken Visions Academy, hé miles, qu'est-ce que c'est
en parlant de nos héros, Marvel
Spider-Man 2 introduira la possibilité
de basculer entre les deux robots d'exploration murale
dans le monde ouvert et grâce à la
puissance de la PlayStation 5. vous pouvez effectuer
ce changement presque instantanément en
offrant une plus grande ville et en jouant comme
non  un mais deux héros araignées étaient de grands
objectifs pour Marvel Spider-Man 2. mais cette
fois-ci, il était tout aussi important de
fournir un plus grand sentiment d'exploration
et de découverte à mesure que vous progressez dans
l'histoire principale. Un certain nombre de nouvelles
activités et de nouveaux scénarios seront
disponibles.  La majorité d'entre eux seront désormais
représentés par des signaux visuels dans le
monde qui attirent votre attention, comme un
troupeau de drones Craven's Talon encerclant
un bâtiment, un symbole mystérieux projeté
dans le ciel ou même un
robot-araignée inconnu émettant depuis l'un des
toits de nombreuses activités comme  les
stores masqués du chasseur qui surplombent
la Grosse Pomme mènent à des défis encore plus grands
tout en rapportant des récompenses dignes et
de nouvelles informations sur le plus grand
chasseur de Marvel, Craven. D'autres mèneront à une
confrontation décisive contre des méchants de Marvel
pas encore vus dans cet univers de Spider-Man.
Les héros araignées ont de nouveaux  AR Tech dans
l'objectif de leurs masques offrant un
aperçu rapide des activités déjà
découvertes ou aidant à en localiser de nouvelles qui n'ont pas
encore été révélées. Vous pouvez toujours vous référer
à l'
application Spider-Man de quartier conviviale améliorée pour suivre rapidement les
zones d'intérêt à proximité que l'application
inclura également.  Les demandes entrantes de ceux qui
appellent Marvel's New York viennent,
certains demanderont l'une ou l'autre araignée ici pour vous
aider. Tandis que d'autres, comme les étudiants de
Brooklyn Visions, faisant appel à des kilomètres,
vous demanderont de mettre le masque d'un
héros spécifique, toutes ces activités,
y compris le crime, doivent être arrêtées.  Les
différentes factions ennemies du jeu alimentent également désormais
le nouveau système de progression de district
qui offre même plus de récompenses et
débloque notre tout nouveau système de voyage rapide,
comme vous pouvez le voir ici. La PlayStation 5
et son SSD vous permettent enfin de vous déplacer à travers
la ville avec très peu de temps d'arrêt.
plus vous explorez de ville et
plus vous accomplissez d'activités,
plus vous pourrez personnaliser
votre héros araignée, cela inclut la maîtrise de
capacités de combat supplémentaires et de
compétences de traversée, l'acquisition de
gadgets améliorés, la mise à niveau via le nouveau
système de technologie de combinaison et bien sûr le déverrouillage de
combinaisons d'araignée supplémentaires.  et nous
parlons de beaucoup de costumes. Marvel
Spider-Man 2 comportera plus de 65 costumes
de films de bandes dessinées et plusieurs
designs originaux et grâce au
tout nouveau système de style de siège, vous
aurez désormais plus de 200 façons différentes de vous
équiper.  votre sympathique quartier
Spider-Man,
au nom d'Insomniac Games, nous ne pourrions
être plus enthousiasmés par ce que cette
ville hispanique a à offrir et par toutes les nouvelles façons dont
vous découvrirez Marvel's New York, nous avons
hâte de vous voir
dans Marvel Spider-  Man 2 lors de son
lancement le 20 octobre uniquement sur
PlayStation 5.
étranger
[Musique]